let's say that i have the complex number
z
and in rectangular form we can write it
as negative 3
plus
negative 3 plus 2 i
so first let's think about where this is
on the complex plane so this is
our imaginary axis
imaginary axis and that is our real axis
real axis and let's see the real part is
negative three so we could go one
two
three to the left of the origin let me
space that out a little bit more evenly
so one
two
three to the left of the origin so
negative 3
and then we have 2i so we're going to go
up 2
so up at 2 in the imaginary direction so
2 just like that
and so z
is real part negative 3
imaginary part 2
z would be right over here in the
complex plane
so that is
z right over there
now what i want to think about are other
ways to essentially specify the location
of z
and in particular instead of giving the
real and imaginary parts essentially the
coordinates here let's think about
giving a direction and a distance to get
to z so for example we could give the
distance from the origin to z
so
let's
let's call this distance r
but the distance by itself isn't enough
to say where z is you have to say in
what direction do you have to go a
distance of r to get to z and so to
specify the direction
to specify the direction
we will have this angle
theta in
radians this angle between the positive
real axis
and this line right over here this line
that or the segment that connect that
connects the origin and z
so if someone gave you this angle and
this distance then you could get 2 z now
what i want you to do right now is pause
this video and see if you can find a
relationship between r theta and
negative 3 and 2. in fact given this
complex number in rectangular form can
you figure out what r and theta
are
well let's think through this a little
bit and to help us that let's remind
ourselves of the unit circle definition
of trig functions because we are going
to use some trig functions to relate r
theta into 2 and negative 3.
so i'm going to construct a unit circle
here
so
construct a unit circle so this right
here is a unit circle circle of radius
1.
so construct a
unit circle
that's a unit circle so by definition
what are the horizontal and vertical
coordinates of this point right over
here where this this line intersects the
unit circle
well this is forming an angle of theta
with the positive real axis
and so the horizontal coordinate over
here by definition
is going to be cosine of theta
cosine of theta that's the unit circle
definition of cosine of theta and the
vertical coordinate is going to be sine
of theta
sine of theta
and so what would well how would what
would the horizontal and vertical
coordinates of this point be we
obviously know they're negative three
and they're two but what would they be
in terms of cosine theta and sine of
theta
well look this point right over here is
a radius of one away from the origin
so this distance right over here that
distance right over here is 1. but now
we are r away from the origin where r
times as far so for r times as far in
that direction then we're going to be r
times as far in the vertical direction
and r times as far in the horizontal
direction we're going to scale all of
we're going to scale everything by r
so the horizontal the horizontal
coordinate of this point right over here
instead of being cosine of theta it's
going to be r times cosine of theta so
this point right over here which we know
is negative 3 is going to be equal to r
cosine of theta and by the same logic
this point over here the vertical
coordinate we're going to scale up sine
theta by r where r times this far so
this point right over here is going to
be r sine theta and we already know that
that's equal to 2
r
sine theta
so given that can we now figure out what
r and theta are
so let's first let's first think about
let's first think about figuring out
what theta is
so to do that let's think about
let's think about some of our our trig
functions so one one trig function that
involves sine theta and cosine theta is
tangent theta so for example we could
say
tangent theta
tangent of our angle
tangent
of theta is equal to
sine of theta
is equal to sine of theta
over cosine of theta
over cosine of theta but we could also
multiply the numerator and denominator
here by r that won't change the value
so that's the same thing as r sine theta
over r cosine of theta and we know r
sine theta is going to be equal to 2
and we know that our cosine of theta is
negative 3.
so this whole thing is going to be
negative
two thirds another way of thinking about
it is
the tangent of this state of tangent of
theta
is going to be the same thing
as the slope of this line
right over here
and what's the slope of that line well
if you start at z and you want to go to
the origin
you're going to go positive 3 in the x
direction
and then you're going to go negative 2
or as you could say positive 3 in the
horizontal direction and then you go
negative 2 in the vertical direction so
the slope is your change in vertical
over change in horizontal it's negative
2 over 3 negative 2 over 3. but now we
can use this to solve for theta to solve
for theta we just take the inverse
tangent of both sides and we get theta
is equal to inverse tangent
of
negative two-thirds
of this thing right over here
so let me copy and paste that
and we could get our calculator out to
figure out what this actually is
so let's turn on let me make sure that i
am in radian mode i am
and so i can take the inverse tangent
of negative 2 divided by 3
which gets us
negative
0.58800 on and on and on so if we round
to the nearest hundredth of a radian
it'd be negative 0.59
so this is
this is approximately
negative 0.59
now is this the right angle is this the
theta is this the theta that we are
looking for well this theta negative
0.59
that's going to get us over here that's
this angle
right over here
that's what the inverse tangent that's
what the inverse tangent gave us and it
makes sense because this this ray is a
continuation of this ray right over here
together they would form a line it has
the same slope but that's not the theta
that we are looking for the theta that
we are looking for is going in the
opposite direction it's halfway around
the circle
so if we think in terms of radians it's
going to be this angle plus it's going
to be this angle plus pi
radians so the theta that we're looking
for isn't
isn't 0
it isn't going to be what our calculator
gives us for this it's going to be this
value
plus pi so theta the theta that we care
about is going to be negative 0.59
roughly
plus
pi let me say approximately just because
i have rounded right over here so let's
let's get the calculator out so let's
take our previous response
and that's just the previous answer
plus pi
plus pi because we're going to go in the
opposite direction so that gives us two
point a roughly 2.55 radians
so this is approximately
2.55 radians is our claim for what theta
is now does that make sense that this
angle that this angle right over here is
2.55 radians
well
this angle if we go straight up that's
pi over 2 radians and pi is 3.14 so
that's going to be 1.57
right one point something like that and
this is pi radius so that's 3.14 5159
keep going on and on and on so 2.55 is
indeed in the right quadrant so that is
right this is going to be an angle of
2.55 radians
now we just have to figure out the
length what r is and that we can just
use the pythagorean theorem for
we could set up a right triangle a right
triangle we know that this distance
this distance right over here
is 2 because this distance right over
here is 2 and we know that this distance
this distance is the coordinate here is
negative 3 but the distance here is just
3.
so we know from the pythagorean theorem
that r squared is equal to 2 squared
is equal to 2 squared
plus 3 squared plus 3 squared or that r
is equal to the square root of 4 plus 9
which is 13.
and so there we have it we have negative
3 so we know r is equal to square root
of 13
and theta is 2.55 radians so using that
information we can now rewrite z in
terms of r
and our theta so now we can say
that z
is equal to instead of negative 3 we can
write it as r cosine theta so we can
rewrite it as
square root of 13 square root of 13
times
the cosine
times the cosine of theta which is we're
saying theta is roughly 2.55 if we round
to the nearest hundredths
plus
2 we already know is r sine of theta so
r is square root of 13
square root of 13
and then
sine
of theta 2.55
and then all of this we could say or all
of this is going to be multiplied times
i
and if we like to simplify it a little
bit or kind of
really make make clear what the r is
here we could factor it out so we could
say
that z
is equal to
square root of 13 square root of 13
times
cosine of 2.55 and once again 2.55 is an
approximation so maybe i should say
approximately equal to
cosine of 2.55
plus
plus i'll throw the i in front plus i
times sine
of 2.55
and so when i rewrote z in this format
right over here it makes it much clearer
what the direction i have to go in is
the direction is 2.55 radians
counterclockwise from the positive real
axis it also says how far i need to go i
need to go square root of 13. so this
this essentially makes the polar it
makes us it makes it clear how we get
there in in kind of a more i guess you
could say polar mindset and that's why
this form of the complex number writing
it this way is called rectangular form
while writing it this way is called
polar form